ideal scenario you have these sides and
three days ahead of time and you're
practicing your memorization - yes
what are those techniques I mean the
easiest way for me to memorize is just
repetition doing it as many times as
possible so ideally I have either a
friend or a family member I've burned my
sister with it a lot in the past growing
up and stuff with just running the scene
with you if you find someone who's
willing to do that that's awesome and
you should get that person a drink after
because it's not fun for them what I
have done in the past in order to not
have to annoy someone to run lines with
me is I've actually recorded the other
lines in the scene and left space for
mine that doesn't help with my acting at
all because you're not hey you don't
have a scene partner you're just done
reading the lines just on a tape
recorder but it definitely helps for
just memorization so I'll normally when
I tape that I'll read the person's line
and then I'll do my line in my head so I
know about how long it takes and then
I'll read the next line you know
so that taping like that has helped me
doing doing an audio tape of all the
other lines in the scene and just
inserting yours if you don't have the
tape I mean the good old fashioned way
of just covering up the other lines and
going down the page line by line with a
sheet of paper that's that's how I
always used to do it so yeah it's really
like there's no I think there's no trick
to it I the more that you get in the
practice of memorizing I feel like it
does if you're I feel like it is kind of
a thing you can practice and get good at
is just the memorization of it but yeah
there's no trick it's just repetition
you